marcel proust en deux minutes
tel est le programme de ce jour puisque
aussi bien gallimard accède pour la
première fois aux désirs de l'écrivain
devoir publier à la recherche du temps
perdu en un seul volume de deux mille
quatre cents pages
il est vrai je ne m'excuserai pas au
ridicule de résumer ou de célébrer cette
oeuvre si difficile et si prodigieuse
qui comme auparavant
rembrandt ou mozart fait accéder à des
dimensions jusqu'alors inexplorés de
l'âme humaine
il me paraît préférable de donner
lecture d'un passage parmi mille autres
possibles de cette oeuvre d'une vie au
sens propre
et de rappeler que marcel proust
commence a dit travailler en 1906 à
l'âge de 35 ans quelques temps après la
disparition de son père vénéré et de sa
mère adorée la recherche ce sont sept
volumes publiés à partir de 1913 et dont
les trois derniers sont posthume une
parenté une descendance avec cette
conquête de la mémoire par la plume
aucune des précédents à rechercher
peut-être du côté du ruisseau des
confessions du chateaubriand des
mémoires d'outre-tombe charles swann
observe de la rue la fenêtre de sa
maîtresse odette de crécy qu'il
soupçonne d'infidélité
et pourtant il était content d'être venu
le tourment qui l'avait forcé de sortir
de chez lui avait perdu de son acuité en
perdant deux sont vagues
maintenant que l'autre vie d'odette dont
il avait eu à ce moment là le brusque et
impuissant soupçons il la tenait là
éclairé en plein par la lampe
prisonnière sans le savoir dans cette
chambre ou quand il le voudrait il
entrerait la surprendre et la capturer
ou plutôt il allait frapper ont volé
comme il faisait souvent quand il venait
très tard ainsi du moins
odette apprendrez qu'il avait su qu'il
avait vu la lumière et entendu la
causerie est lui qui tout à l'heure cela
représentait comme se riant avec l'autre
de ses illusions
maintenant c'est est ce qu'il voyait
confiants dans leurs erreurs trompé en
somme par lui qu'il croyait bien loin
d'ici et qui lui
avait déjà qu'il allait frapper au
volant est peut-être ce qu'il ressentait
en ce moment de presque agréable c'était
autre chose aussi que l'apaisement d'un
doute et d'une douleur un plaisir de
l'intelligence
e